what's up y'all i'm joelle and for the
next week i'm going to attempt to
recreate the favorite foods of the
incredible
talented iconic world-renowned korean
girl group
black pink i've been a blank for a while
now so i was so excited when i saw that
my friend jasmine made a video up on
tasty showing how to recreate some of
blackpink's favorite foods so i'll be
using some of her recipes as well as a
bunch of my own
to dedicate one day to each member's
favorite foods plus a little bonus day
at the end of foods they've seen
blackpink eat all together i'm very
excited and let's get started with the
week so we're starting off this
challenge with miss jenny kim
the powerhouse and she is just a jack of
all trades
incredibly talented when it comes to
singing rapping and dancing
jenny is known for being really
dedicated to health and fitness and
when she's preparing for their comebacks
she's apparently very consistent in
having an avocado salad and detox juice
for breakfast so that's what i decide to
have and when it comes to a detox juice
i know that lemon cayenne turmeric and
ginger are really popular ingredients
so we'll see how that tastes well i
don't think i would opt to eat salad
for breakfast on a regular basis i feel
like as far as a breakfast salad goes
this is pretty good we got some eggs
some protein the avocado
it's very satisfying this however is a
part of the meal that i am
not as excited about it's not the worst
thing i've ever had
i feel like knowing that this is good
for me and it's gonna help like cleanse
my bowels or whatever
um makes me feel better drinking it it
is now lunch time
jenny really enjoys ordering avocado
sandwiches so that is what i made for my
lunch today it's just like a nice
open-faced avocado sandwich
my toast broke you know i said i would
eat blackpink's favorite foods this week
i never said i would look as good as
them
while eating it you know jenny is kind
of known for being the most stylish
member
being really particular about what she
wears so she'll collaborate with
blackpink stylist to decide what she
wears for tours or
promos so obviously with her impeccable
fashion taste she's earned the nickname
human chanel it is dinner time and i'm
so excited
this recipe was featured in jasmine's
video on tasty
and is also a recipe from the queen
herself that jenny shared on a v
live and that is pollock row with rice
it's a pretty simple recipe just with
some white rice topped with polygrow
avocado and egg yolk and seasoned with a
little bit of sesame oil and i honestly
feel really bad destroying this to eat
it because it looks so cute it all ends
up in the same place anyways all right
wow yes chef it's so simple but the
textures go together so well and the
avocado
and the pollock roll balance each other
out salt wise perfectly this beautiful
melody of flavors
we could not end day one without sharing
a black pink fact
and today's fact is that the name of
black pink is meant to represent the
multi-dimensionality
of the group as women in the
entertainment industry a yg
entertainment rep
apparently said that the meaning of
black pink aims to contradict the common
perception of the color pink pink is
commonly used to portray prettiness but
blackpink
actually means to say that pretty isn't
everything it also symbolizes that they
are a team that encompasses not only
beauty but also great
talent alrighty y'all it is rose day's
day rosea is a vocalist for blackpink
and she has an
amazing voice but she's also a really
incredible dancer
i absolutely love rosie partially
because she's known as blackpink's
foodie having the nickname foodie chang
coming from her korean name
park tang she's kind of known for eating
a lot of weird food combinations and on
a radio show she said one of her recent
food combo obsessions has been goguma
korean sweet potato and
kimchi so that's what i am having for my
breakfast i got my potato
we get a nice piece of kimchi
we definitely have like a sweet savory
spicy thing going on but this is good
the warm potato and the cold kimchi
compliment each other so well
rosie girl you're really onto something
this is yummy i am so
excited apparently one of rosa's
favorite dishes is the classic
korean corn dog she said that she only
likes it covered in sugar so
i got one with potato because we know
that rose likes potatoes
and the light sugar
oh my gosh pop this has cheese and a
corn dog
in it the texture is out of this world
you can obviously hear the crunch but
it's so good and with the sweet chili
sauce is like the cherry on top
a little bit of a rush to get home so
i'm gonna get this to my sister before
it gets cold i was trying to get the hot
dog to my sisters and i dropped it on
the floor
but it's on the ground like rose new
single
is there an innards okay my conclusion
is that it's good the potato with sugar
actually isn't that sweet it tastes a
lot better than i thought it would
cheers
taking a midday break from work and i
want to be a rose a day without some
flamin hot cheetos which is apparently
one of our favorite snacks and you know
you always got to eat it with some
chopsticks while i'm here i figured
might as well share
today's blackpink fun fact when
blackpink song
debuted at 55 on the billboard hot 100
they became the first korean girl group
ever ranked with a predominantly
non-english song don't get me wrong i
love being able to sing along with my
favorite k-pop groups in english because
i'm still learning korean my korean
sucks but i also love seeing non-english
media being celebrated in pop culture
and i hope that as we move forward and
as genres like k-pop become a little
more globalized that people will still
really see
the value in people being able to sing
in their own native languages
even though rose is ethnically korean
she actually
grew up in australia there was an
interview where she was asked what kind
of foods that she misses from home that
she can't get in korea and one of the
foods that she listed was shepherd's pie
so that's what i decided to make for
dinner
it's my first time making it so please
don't judge for those of you guys who've
never had shepherd's pie
it's a combination of normally a meat
stewed with some veggies kind of in like
a gravy
and topped with mashed potatoes i don't
think i made enough mashed potatoes
because it was a very scant layer on top
i personally really love shepherd's pie
because it's super hearty and it's like
a one-dish meal so i wouldn't rate my
shepherd's pie very highly it's all
right
jose i'll improve my shepherd's pie good
morning y'all and it is
jisoo day jisoo is the oldest member of
blackpink and one of the main vocalists
she has the voice
of an angel and she's also really funny
she has a great sense of humor she's
actually also the only blackpink member
to have been born
and raised in korea for her whole
childhood so
in typical korean fashion one of her
favorite foods
is rice and it is such a versatile food
so of course this morning i wanted to
doctor up my rice a little bit and make
it into some juk which
is just a really classic korean rice
porridge
i also thought i would accompany my
breakfast with an iced americano because
i've seen so many photos and like clips
of jisoo with an iced coffee and
i tend to believe that it's not just
regular iced coffee but an ice americano
just because they're so common to get in
korea
i cannot describe how comforting the
smell of rice porridge is to me
it's just so satisfying like the chicken
broth just soaks into all the rice
espresso is so good blackpink is often
on the road
traveling and they try all different
kinds of cuisines i saw jisoo
in their reality show black pink house
having some shrimp tempura after
a really late night of performing one of
their concerts in japan
so i decided i'd try to make some shrimp
tempura as well
i'm just having my shrimp tempura with
some rice some kimchi in my favorite
japanese barbecue sauce oh my gosh
it's so good with the sauce oh the
crunch is so satisfying and of course i
have to have it with my rice jesus fave
while i'm eating i might as well share
today's blackpink fact blackpink is not
just making waves in music but also
in fashion each of the four members of
blackpink serve as a global ambassador
for a luxury fashion house with jisoo
for dior
rose for saint laurent lisa for celine
and jenny
for chanel in between taking care of her
dog talcum
and being you know a worldwide pop
sensation
apparently one of jesus's favorite
pastimes is gaming one of the mobile
games she's been seen playing
is cookie run which i remember from like
middle school
i decided to download it and just give
it a try you know in honor of jisoo
i feel like it's been so long since i've
played games when i was thinking about
it at first i was like how in the world
does jisu have time to play games in
between rehearsals
and touring and all the stuff that she
has to do but she's flying she's
traveling while on tour
so i feel like it does make sense that
jesus was able to play games you know
while on the road or just you know
killing some time and relaxing i died
that was so fast any jisu stand knows
that it wouldn't be
in eating like jisu day without what
dish
that's right chicken skewers baby there
are literal compilations out there of
jisoo
expressing her love for chicken and she
even made a song about it
in one episode of black pink house the
casual version of this that you'll see
sold oftentimes on the streets in korea
it's called dakotchi
i think i'm saying that right and i made
mine with two different sauces one is a
soy sauce garlic base and the second one
is a gochujang red pepper based sauce i
definitely like a little saucier than
the ones jisoo ate in black pink house
there's one really good it's so savory
and it gets like a little charred from
the grill and it's so yummy i'm amazed
also that the chicken is like still
juicy because i always overcook my
chicken
yeah i was nervous with this one i hope
it is up to g2 standards of being a
songworthy
chicken skewer i am so excited for lisa
day
lisa is the maknae the youngest member
of the group and she's the main dancer
and rapper she is so powerful she's also
known to bring a lot of positive energy
to the group which i think is so so
sweet and
a well-known fact about lisa is that
she's actually from thailand not korea
to honor lisa's home country for
breakfast i thought i'd make tom yum
soup it is a thai
hot and sour soup with seafood and it's
super super flavorful and will
definitely
wake me up this morning there's a lot of
really fun ingredients that i've
actually never cooked with before
she's spicy she's got a kick i like that
there's so many layers to the flavor of
this dish it has a little bit of
sweetness which i think honestly comes
from the chili paste
and the shrimp but also a lot of like
savory umami from the fish sauce
and of course we got a lot of heat not
only does lisa do
obviously all the black pink promo and
work that the other girls are doing but
she also creates her own
dance videos on her personal youtube
channel called lily film and she'll just
make these
super high production dance concept
videos and they honestly
are so high quality they could be like
their own music video
i'm so impressed with the fact that
while she's in this world famous girl
group she's also creating so much
additional content
for viewers i feel like all the black
paint girls do that so well of just
doing so much for their fans for
releases day i was tempted to make
kanjitang the
korean stew that jasmine made in her
video for tasty but i feel like lisa
likes so many other foods that i just
want to include
a good variety i don't know if i heard
this correctly so don't quote me on this
but i feel like i've heard her say that
she said that she would want her last
meal
on earth to be sushi so you know i had
to go get it i know she like spiced so i
got some spicy tuna i also had to get
some sweet thai tea
since there's this episode of black pink
house where she's posing with milk tea
like an advertisement in the girls hotel
room and they're all making fun of her
so
i always thought it was crazy impressive
how not only are most k-pop idols
required to speak korean
obviously but they also have to learn
japanese since oftentimes k-pop groups
will release japanese versions of their
songs and they obviously do a lot of
tours and press in japan
so blows my mind one of my favorite like
most
heartwarming moments of blackpink's
reality show is when they're in thailand
they were surprised by lisa's parents
coming in to create
this beautiful feast for them and the
girls all saw the table before lisa's
parents came out but what gave away
the fact that it was lisa's family that
prepared the meal was
this fondue pot that lisa remembered
from when she was a child
her stepdad is actually a swiss chef so
i decided to replicate the fondue that
he surprised lisa with i've actually
never made fondue for myself like this
before but i'm very excited to try
oh my gosh this is so good oh you can
hear the sizzle
the fondue is interesting i feel like i
can really taste like the white wine
coming through
and i put a lot more garlic the recipe
called
but i feel like garlic always makes
everything taste better obviously have
to share
today's black pink fun fact and today's
fun fact is that
black pink was positioned as an
extremely international group with
three-fourths of the group spending time
outside of korea
while growing up and with lisa actually
being yg
their entertainment company's first
international star
so with their diverse backgrounds it
makes sense that they're able to connect
with and relate to just a really wide
array of fans
that also led to them being the first
k-pop girl group to perform at coachella
it would be a travesty to let lisa's day
go by without
doing a little dancing so my sister
micah and i are gonna try to learn
the kill this love dance which i
realized i can't show you with the music
because copyright you can see our
process and us trying to do the stance
over some nice
copyright royalty-free music well it is
the last day of our challenge
so today i'm just making a bunch of
foods that i've seen all the girls enjoy
together particularly in their show
in one of those episodes jenny wakes up
early to make all the girls pancakes
with fruit and all these
beautiful little toppings which i
thought was so sweet i am attempting to
make
japanese souffle pancakes as well you
don't make it fancy
but i know these are notoriously
difficult to make inga has a video up if
you want to follow her recipe who knows
how many times i'll need to try to make
these before they're right
despite my many failures they're well
worth the effort the texture is like out
of this world it's so fluffy
and light and the sweetness is so subtle
also makes me feel better that in black
pink house as
jen was making her pancakes she kept
flipping them wrong because that's
exactly what i did
you and me miss jenny both struggling
with our pancakes for lunch today i'm
making another dish that i've seen
blackpink cook together and that is
kimchi bokkeumbap or kimchi fried rice
they made it specifically with pork
belly and seasoned it with gochujang so
that's what i'm doing today
i decided to pair my kimchi book about
with a chun gochu just a
green chili pepper in the episode of
black pancas when they were eating this
rose was just munching on this pepper
and really often eaten with gochujang
just dipped in and eaten raw it's just
like a really yummy fresh way to break
up the
greasy heaviness of the fried rice
it is the final meal of our black pink
eating challenge but we're ending off
with a bang it's inspired by the episode
of blackpink house when they go to the
jinjibung which is just
a korean spa there's charcoal saunas
and you can get your body scrubbed down
but they also normally sell snacks
literally so relatable
they want to go have a spa day but were
so distracted by the snacks they had
sweet potatoes
dumplings tuck rice cakes noodles corn
all this stuff i'm not even gonna lie to
y'all this has probably been one of the
meals that i'm most excited for
in this whole week's challenge because
it's just 80 carbs i will say the only
part of this meal that i actually
cooked is the sauna eggs these eggs are
slow roasted
and they're really commonly served at
any korean spa
it's actually perfect to pair with my
tap goodie which is a combination of
chapagetti which is black bean noodles
and neo goodie which is a
seafood ramen brand in korea it got so
popular for people
to make the two together that now they
just manufacture like
bowls of chapo goodie which has the two
mixes mixed together for you
but in blackpink house rose was really
feeding in for some black bean noodles
so that's why i decided to get this
and before i get into dessert i wanted
to finish off this meal with our
blackpink fact
on spotify blackpink is the second most
streamed kpop artist after bts
making them the top most streamed kpop
girl group
reaching 300 million streams in 2020.
i didn't want to end off our last day
without a little of dessert i'm having
some [ __ ]
which rose was very enthusiastic about
getting at the kimchi bong it is a sweet
rice drink it's so refreshing and so
sweet and it has a little bit of a
grainy texture because there's actually
grains of rice like
floating around in there sadly as we're
at the end of our eating like blackpink
challenge
looking back in the photos trying to
figure out which day was my favorite
and i have to say i think the winning
day from this week was jesus
the juke and the chicken skewers the
shrimp were all
top-notch i would highly recommend
trying to make any of those dishes on
your own
as well as honestly anything from this
week was so delicious and so much fun so
i hope you all enjoyed and thank you so
much for watching and if there's any
other celebrity or group that you'd like
me to try to eat like please let me know
in the comments down below and i'll see
you in the next one
bye
you